leurs oeuvres nous interpelle où nous
amusent à tour les artistes de street
art utilise graffiti au pochoir pour
égayer les vieux murs de la ville d'un
jour à l'autre ses dessins change c'est
même l'un des principes de cet art
vivant sauf qu'aujourd'hui la communauté
aimerait bien sortir de là de
l'illégalité est disposée en fin de
parcours dédié lucas chopin
annabelle et guide conférencière
spécialisée dans le street art avec
l'office du tourisme de tours elle a eu
l'idée de proposer des déambulations
dans la ville pour mettre en avant cet
art et si ces parcours sont connus à
l'avance le street art lui réservent
parfois malgré tout quelques surprises
on commence par le parking gambetta en
règle générale on fait les différents
niveaux et puis après on sort à l'ère où
on n'est pas la brique demain en visite
j'aille à un endroit bien précis et
zulte ya pu rien à monter ça fait partie
du jeu on est dans l'imprévu donc c est
un côté aussi assez sympathique dans ce
sens là les oeuvres de street art sont
difficiles à répertorier c'est pourquoi
annabelle travaille régulièrement avec
les administrateurs du groupe facebook
street art tour city eux aussi
passionnés ils sont bien décidés à
donner de l'importance à cet art de rue
qu'ils considèrent comme trop pas
visibiliser dans la capitale tourangelle
ya plein d'autres villes des métropoles
etc qui font des parcours de street art
et nos atouts by un grand vide en fait
et du coup nous ce qu'on aimerait c'est
voilà faire connaître partager et puis
va faire découvrir le street art sur toi
des efforts qui seraient vains sur le
soutien des principaux intéressés
aujourd'hui ils sont nombreux à décorer
discrètement la ville et si pour
beaucoup on observe la notoriété prendre
de l'ampleur l'objectif n'est pas
spécialement d'être dans la lumière
alors moi c'est d'abord pour m'amuser
j'ai souvent des petits personnages sur
moi dans mon sac j'ai souvent mon tube
de colle sachant que c'est soit de la
colle à bois soit de la colle à papier
peint donc c'est de la colle qui dégrade
pas c'est l'occasion qui fait le larron
c'est voilà c'est j'attends le bon
moment je sais pas la désobéissance
non l'idée de mettre de la couleur sur
le morne murs gris moi je suis pas dans
une démarche de de sa cage j'essaye
d'embellir en collant en peignant des
choses dans les villes ça va attirer
l'oeil et attiser la curiosité
il ya le côté adrénaline qui est hyper
intéressant et le côté un peu inconnu
quoi le côté anonyme qui est chouette où
les gens se demandent si c'est est tous
assez rigolo quoi c'est un peu un jeu
moi je trouve à tour le street art a de
beaux jours devant lui prochain objectif
obtenir des zones dédiées à cette
expression grâce au concours de la
mairie